so my name is frost Hamid I'm a software
engineer at Netflix and I'm currently
working on machine learning
infrastructure and today I was gonna
talk to you about I reduce civilian
machine learning systems hopefully
that's ok cuz that's kind of like the
only talk I have prepared so today we're
gonna focus on like defining what we
mean by reproducibility especially in
the context of machine learning systems
like a big surprise that's a tough talk
on why it matters and kind of outlined
some like real work on benefits and
hopefully illustrate that through some
real-world example examples and then
we're gonna talk about how we actually
addressed our reproducibly at Netflix
that before we get into all of that I
figured it would be helpful to have a
couple of brief primers one about
machine learning at Netflix so typically
when people hear that they think of our
personalized video recommendation which
is very understandable it's you know one
of the I guess more more user-visible
use cases very important to us but
before a title even hits your screen
there's actually a lot happening
underneath the hood and machine learning
is applied at every kind of step in the
funnel so from pre-production and
production such as helping determine the
value of content optimizing production
schedules so figuring out which actors
and actresses need to be where and the
order in which sets need to be shot in
to more streaming on system use cases
such as figuring out the optimal layout
of our content and ricean caching
figuring out how to best utilize our
infrastructure for job scheduling
intelligent job scheduling and
preemption in pre and post launch trying
to predict the effect of certain tiles
have on our journey retention rates
figured out the fact of our marketing
and really there's just hundreds of
different business business Houston and
Netflix that require machine learning we
depend on machine learning to some
degree
but reproducibility pretty much comes
with all of them and now just like let's
talk about machine learning in general
so something maybe it's infographic
taken from paper published a few years
back and it does a pretty good job of
illustrating a powerful point so what we
consider or what a lot of people think
about when they think about ml is really
just like that small barely visible
black box in the middle which is like
the machine like the ML code and a lot
of times this is just like maybe eight
lines of Karass code but when we're
talking about machine learning systems
in production like you would actually
probably find yourself spending way more
time on these other components like data
verification compute resource management
deployment and serving infrastructure
okay so now we got that out of the way
let's go back to nine hand which is
talking about reproducibility and like
what that really means
I'm sure most of you probably have some
idea of like what the definition of
reproducibility is and it's probably
something to the fact of obtaining
consistent results through repeated
trials right it's more or less something
like that but what does that really mean
in the context of machine learning so
let's kind of just take a step back
start with a blank slate and figure out
what components we need to have a
reproducible ml system all right so one
you probably need the model right house
is right there uh you could get like you
know um your prediction inference
results but you can't really do do much
after that you might need to if you want
to deploy to a different execution
environment you might need to recompile
it if you want to like build on it you
might need to look at the code you might
need to understand how it works
so how false is have the code on and you
don't have either better than means that
usually takes me a few iterations on the
model before I like the
to production so you probably need some
kind of version right um but you know
now this is like that new we've had
version control on software engineering
for like 40 years but that's really
still not enough to create a fully
reproducible machine train system right
oh so fully repeats train for example
you need like the hyper primers and
associated metadata of the model uh
you'd also need the libraries so which
version of tensorflow you are using so
now we're talking about dependency
management which is a pretty hairy
problem especially when you talk about
dependencies and transitive dependencies
and you know that's still very difficult
right even in traditional software
engineering well mission Danny but again
still not enough
you probably data right you need the
training test validation data it's
produced the same model but again
there's still more right um there's a
lot of inherent randomness and many
machine learning systems like what
random weights did you start with what
seeds you start with and really maybe
even environmental factors right here
just and I got hit by solar flare flips
and bits really hard to kind of capture
and reproduce so we'll just call that
entropy right um so to say your system
is fully reproducible you kind of need
to provide all these components all
right um and we I guess typically talk
about reproducibility is binary
construct so either something is
reproducible or it's not but especially
in the context of machine I mean it's
really more helpful to think of it as a
spectrum right so you start all the way
on the left from not reproducible or
minimally reproducible to kind of like
the Holy Grail what you're able to
reproduce everything I'd down to the bit
and as you move up kind of stepladder
you unlock you know more and more
practical features which kind of brings
us to our next topic which is why are
you serving matters right so I know a
lot of you probably have some sort of
science background and like since grade
school you've kind of been drilled that
real science needs to have
reproducibility means to get the same
results but kind of like what benefits
do get like from like a business use
case for example um so the best way to
really illustrate that is to just kind
of go over some little world examples um
or real world like examples so let's say
you're a data scientist right which for
a lot of you that's probably true so
you're not too big of a leap in terms of
imagination um so you know you're
working on this project very successful
great job promotions all the way you
move on to your next project but you
know after a few months you need to go
back either to retrain something you've
already deployed or you know the
business use case has changed you need
to modify your model no problem you are
you you know you follow best practices
you have your code and github and pull
it down you're like you know I just need
to make two lines of changes I'm good to
go
uh but then it doesn't really work right
so it turns out that there was a lot of
dependency drift right so you find
yourself and kind of pensee management
hell for two weeks until you get out um
but now smooth sailing right and you
figure out that you know what I'm going
to run my flow every day so this doesn't
happen to me again use Conaway java
scheduling framework or you know just
playing crontab but you still run into
issues um you get these transient errors
um you can't figure it out you get these
unintelligible error messages you
escalate to an engineer um you know
engineer might not be able to reproduce
you might not even are the engineer
might not even know how to run your flow
or training you know maybe they're just
drinking coffee so it just takes like a
while to get back alright so you burn a
few days there um it turns out that the
you know pi arrow
version you're using in production is
old and different than the one you're
using locally that's why you can
reproduce tissue locally and you know
the version in prod like doesn't handle
certain datatypes correctly that you get
that resolved again smooth sailing but
then you hit another issue Oh a really
nation but you're so successful that
they decide to expand the scope of your
project and they add another day of
science to help you out and their
science is excited already makes an
impact so naturally the first thing on
the person does is pull down on the
project try to replicate what is already
dry in production but unable to get
working on dependencies are off
configurations off so you spend kind of
a week kind of helping get your coworker
up to speed so again you're like right
now you're wasting a lot of time it's
been like around three weeks
um burnt and now you enter comic
development phase right on your newly
expanded scope and especially early on
it's very typical to like experiment on
a lot of different dimensions right
you're changing kind of what features
you're using hyper parameters Model
Model types etc and it's coming out very
easy to lose track there you can find
yourself in a situation where you're not
really sure how you got the results like
what version of the feature extraction
library you can use what version of
tensorflow we're using what table were
you reading from so like you might end
up spending a lot of mental battles just
trying to organize your different
experiments and in like some of the
worst cases you might end up rerunning
your experiments just because you're not
really sure how you got those results so
I guess kind of like what what happened
here what led to this like series of
unfortunate events
like what was missing why did you have
to spend like around a month um working
on
I guess stuff that was really outside of
your job description that wasn't really
core to what your job was about so one
thing is trust I did Billy it's depend
on your system um to like run
indefinitely with without any or minimum
human intervention and being able to
trust the results that produces right
and like being able to take whatever you
built and just run it in a trust that it
will be able to run an arbitrary
environment uh and coming from Netflix
where we're like a cloud first
infrastructure or based cloud first
infrastructure we don't really own any
of our own data centers pretty much
everything is treated as ephemeral so
this is very important to us another one
is debugging right so energy and the
engineer will tell you that 90% of like
resolving an issue or a bug being able
to reproduce it consistently as soon as
you Det do that it's just kind of a
matter of time before you're able to
deploy fix or resolve the issue and for
non engineers in the room I'm sure
you've all faced the frustration of some
engineer just closing a ticket as can't
reproduce it's not that the engineer is
lazy I mean like they could be lazy but
it's also sometimes impossible to or
like very difficult to reproduce it an
issue without with incomplete
information collaboration right um
allowing multiple people to work on the
same data science projects I know a lot
of like today scientists are count lone
Wolf's but for some projects there's
like several like a team of circuit data
scientist working on it um and also like
removing the fear factor right a lot of
times people are scared to jump in on
like a new project in or like it because
they're worried about breaking something
right so if you're able to give them the
ability to take whatever giant
production run it locally
Brian dev environment or some sort of
safe environment where they could just
kind of play around and get their feet
wet
really improve in terms of collaboration
rapid prototyping um so the ability to
iterate quickly without spending too
much mental bandwidth to keep track of
the mundane and these are all the all
the practical benefits or all these
practical benefits come from having a
more reproducible system so that's kind
of why it matters so if we um kind of go
back to earlier and take the infographic
from the beginning of the slideshow and
discuss and like the different
components that we talked about and we
create like a ml system stuck towards
the top you'll see model training
feature engineering etc and is give a
deeper you see stuff like you know job
scheduling compute resource management
you know data warehouse management and
as even with down the stack um it
becomes less and less relevant to data
scientist right um for example I've
never kind of had a conversation with
the day scientists who carried about
weather like his MA whether his model
training ran on a computer using
kubernetes and races right I've never
had that conversation
similarly um from like an infrastructure
point of view the higher up you go on
the stack um the less like software
engineers and data engineers my care
like most infrastructure engineers would
not care how you handle your categorical
data for example so now it's probably a
good time to segue to how we handled
reproducibility at Netflix so the way we
adjusted is Provost internal with this
pythonic framework developed internally
called meddlesome uh and it was
developed for data science projects so
I'm only gonna give up kind of
high-level overview but what meta flow
is there's already other talks online
specifically devoted to meta flow and
before I upload the slides I'll make
sure to to link you to those
on much better speakers than me say she
probably into those so meta flow
provides a lot of features now I'm only
gonna dive into the ones that are most
relevant to reproducibility but a
high-level meta flow is really just
meant to kind of package the entire
machine learning stack and provide a
more human friendly interface so des
scientists could focus more towards the
top of the stack animala training future
engineering and no we're not worried
about everything below and
infrastructure engineers could focus on
providing pave past instabilities to the
other components and focus on I guess
create a crane more leverage to support
a much larger org so just to give you
like a feel of how a meta flow project
looks like it's really just based off I
could dag execution flow so you have you
define what's called a flow each
instance or run of a flow or iteration
of flow is called a run or run is made
up of many steps so start a be joining
and they're all distinct steps and you
step could be one or more tasks so on
the right you'll see this associate code
it's pretty simple just pure Python or
any function that's a step needs to add
step decorator not you know to shock in
there in terms of gaming um and you know
everything else is just regular Python
code so not much magic this is an
example for each so the overall
structure of the as a dag needs to be
static at least for now but you can have
some some parts could be dynamic which
is the size of the the for each split in
this case um here it's three but it
could uh it can be dynamic and it's
another example of one example where one
step contains many tasks so in this case
step a is made up of three tasks
so let's jump into some of the features
that den meta flow provides um that
relevant to reproducibility so one is
code packaging so we talked about how we
need to have code version code to be
able to have a reproducible system so a
metaphor does is it takes your code your
execution environment or working
directory packages all up push this to
s3 uh and you want and this is done it
for every run in iteration so it's all
versions and can be accessed later then
the flow also provides dependency
management so every task is actually in
its own isolated runtime amount so you
could do something like this where you
know you have a step a in step B and
each of them actually use conflicting
versions at the st. library and again
this could be done because they're
actually in separate environments in
some cases that they're not even writing
on the same machine uh and as you can
see we use Conda here for dependency
management we did consider a few other
alternatives uh you know you could use
pip but you know it doesn't really
provide runtime isolation on its own not
very long it's not language agnostic
it's very specific to - um but it is low
overhead
there's docker which does provide
runtime isolation is language agnostic
that I really wouldn't call it a low
overhead especially if you're not coming
from an engineering backgrounds can get
kind of complex continue dating and
technically you'd still not use pip or
something like that to install the
packages when you're baking the image I
also in terms of iteration speed it's
kind of slower end if you need to
rebuild the image every time and we fell
Kondo comprar vided as the the best of
both worlds there um
metadata persistence so meta flow does
persist does provide some sort of
metadata persistence baked in so it
automatically persists inversions all
instance variables as what we call
artifacts so in this example we have
self DF and you could you just think of
that as a panda's data frame or
something like that
and that's defined and start but we we
could still access access it and end
even though it's a separate execution
environment so all of these are made
accessible and subsequent steps and
these artifacts are also accessible from
other flows and can be little using the
client API so you can even pull them
down into a notebook if you want do some
analysis share results etc and the way
we do that on is pretty simple I find
not too surprising and then we take the
the penance data frame you serialize it
using pickle something like that so you
get some bytes we compress the bytes
here we do like you know I guess kind of
some standard hashing so we hashed the
the byte values and use that as it as
the key and then we put the entire
payload in s3 and the reason why we do
the hashing is to avoid storing
duplicate data so if like your data
hasn't changed and you you know store
that large pandas dataframe under
multiple different names
we won't duplicate the data so it
reduces our memory footprint but overall
with I guess the compression the hashing
on the actual cost is relatively low the
logs are also persistent in a different
manner that you know standard out
standard air are accessible later meta
flow does provide some isolation I
wouldn't really call it complete by any
means since these are like running
arbitrary Python code there's really no
straightforward way for us to prevent
any side-effects
but if you know two data scientists are
you know running the same flu we do
provide some namespace isolation for the
runs metadata and artifacts associated
with it um so you know if Jesse pulls
like their latest prediction flow run
they'll get eight whereas Traci will get
six so you could have potentially
multiple people working on the same
project without necessarily stepping on
each other's toes so going back to this
diagram where does metaphor kind of land
in the stack so we provided um you know
model code and versioning my data we
have defensive management but we don't
really persist all the data right so we
learned about here um so we don't
persist everything by default we do
obviously store the artifacts as
previously mentioned um but you know
storing all the data could be
prohibitively expensive especially at
like gigabytes or terabytes of training
data
um and to store that on interpret every
run every iteration is pretty expensive
and we actually found that in most cases
you don't really need to do that
especially do you have proper data
hygiene so if you treat the underlying
data is immutable
um have proper partitions so like you
for example you have a hive table you
partition by date and you just don't
like the store the partition key as
artifacts that usually works out pretty
well um you know works out for our use
cases I'm not saying it works for all
use cases so you know you're watching
some YouTube no need to leave like
hateful comments but for the most part
it works out well for entropy also you
don't really do much here the the value
the cost benefit analysis doesn't they
work technically you can store some of
the noise as artifacts like which seeds
used on or random White's you used but
you know we don't really go too far
there
so how it's well three that's it our
example from earlier
I know season two is usually worse but
hopefully that's not the case here so
you could basically kick off where you
left off right um we kind of would like
depends management you're not gonna face
the same issues before uh debugging is
made simpler
so everything's reproducible and you
know even in the case we described
earlier you products you're when you're
gonna run into the bug at all just cuz
you kind of have that execution
environment based in for use um when you
have a new person joining team you know
again relating back to the first point
you have effortless run ability so
person could come in day one start being
productive and then in terms of rapid
prototyping um you know all iterations
are namespace and persisted so you could
kind of have like multiple streams going
at once and the framework itself kind of
keeps track of experiments and durations
for you
so uh Netflix is kami leader so I feel I
need to put in some plugs we are hiring
I don't know why I made the jobs link so
small at the bottom but you know it is
what it is aha so that's specifically a
job link for the machine learning
structure team we're looking for a
couple of you know your colleagues to
help us out um but I do encourage you to
just go to jobs on Netflix calm and
browse all the postings there's some
great positions out there and we'd love
to have people like you I also want to
note that we are looking into open
sourcing meta flow so if you or your
organization wants to give it a try
please contact us all right talk to me
after this talk and that's that's it so
I got
[Applause]
yeah there's Q&A - I forgot about that
hey thank you for the great talk this
looks like a really amazing project I'm
curious how you invalidate the cache
artifacts so if your data scientist
changes part of their flow code do you
invalidate all the all the cache
artifacts or just the ones that depended
on that code somehow oh well we'll reap
is persisted for every run right oh so
everything will be read regenerated
every time you run the code yeah so are
you specifically talking about let's see
are you talking about like this slide
he's one you when we like purchase the
bike data frame yes exactly
yeah so if so again we we hash based off
the bytes so if the data didn't change
we're not going to reaper Syst it but if
the data did change we will read persist
it so you're not taking advantage of the
caching to speed up later runs it's just
for reproducibility yeah great thank you
yeah that uh that since you brought that
up there is a resume feature so you can
actually resume from any step from any
previous run cuz it any ones have more
questions quick question on what is like
the typical or recommended size of a
task in terms of volume of data it might
process the runtime is it blocked really
small function or is it something there
or an hour I guess like sizes on like a
broad term because it could be like in
terms of compute resources resources
just your number of tasks and I guess
like in terms of the framework itself
there's not too many limitations I guess
it really depends on the underlying
infrastructure hopefully plugged into
you know Netflix is an infrastructure
which is built on top of AWS so in terms
of like storage
that's three so it's pretty big we don't
worry too much about it
in terms of like compute resources it is
like elastic scaling so it's super
important we could scale up but there's
associate cost with it so it really
depends what you mean by size yes more
questions to please all right please
thank you
ferrous for the great talk